hi guys this is a kill and today I'll be
discussing about the differences
comparisons of public cloud versus
private cloud versus hybrid cloud model
so in today's session I'll be discussing
about the use cases of these cloud
models and the advantages the
differences along with that the
architecture and the companies and that
are using these cloud models but before
that I would request you to subscribe to
our channel you can find the link just
below this video at the right side so
let's sir understand these three
different cloud models based on the use
case so the first use cases there is an
insufficient data storage and
duplication that means that was a
problem which we were facing before the
public cloud now this has been resolved
using the public cloud model because in
that model we can use the public cloud
expand and share and syncing capacities
as well make it more accessible and
backup of data is much simpler in the
case of a public cloud now the another
use case is with respect to the private
cloud the problem was in that how we can
use the specified hardware as well as
with our specifications or our needs so
this has been something which is
resolved with the introduction of a
private cloud in which the private cloud
fetches hardware as per the requirement
of an application the third use cases
that how to handle the high peak traffic
and that is something which is resolved
with the introduction of the hybrid
cloud which says that with the hybrid
cloud we can manage the traffic levels
during the peak usage time periods now
let's understand the definition of these
three different cloud models first of
all let's start with the public cloud so
the public cloud says that it is a cloud
computing infrastructure it's basically
about the cloud computing infrastructure
that is located on the premises of the
company that offer the services so
wherever the company is located at which
is providing you the public cloud
services the infrastructure the data
center would be located at their
premises itself let's understand the
definition of a private cloud it says
that the private cloud means using a
cloud infrastructure only for our
dedicated customer or the organization
so you can have a dedicated
infrastructure for your clients or the
organization and that would not be
shared with the other users let's
understand the definition of a hybrid
cloud the hybrid cloud is basically the
combination of the public and the
private clocked it's based on the
purpose and the requirements so here we
are discussing about the hybrid cloud
definition with respect to the cloud
native approach so whenever you discuss
about the cloud native approach you
always discuss about the combination of
a public cloud plus private cloud which
is basically a hybrid cloud now the
company that provides the services only
related to the public cloud is the
global dots so Global dot is one of the
company that offers worldwide public
cloud services whereas the company that
offers the private cloud kind of a
services that means dedicated to a
particular organization or the customer
that is Dell so we know about Dell it is
one of the companies that offer the
private cloud services and in case of a
hybrid cloud services iBM is the company
which offers and the hybrid cloud and
offer services to the customers now
there is one feature in the cloud cloud
deployment models which is called as the
tenancy tenancy is basically kind of a
virtual partitioning of the resources
and all those resources will be kept
isolated so in case of a tenancy in the
case of a public cloud it is basically a
multi tenant kind of a set up in which
data of many organizations probably a
different organization in different
geographies can store the data in a
shared environment since it's a multi
tenant so their data would be completely
isolated to another organizations data
as well now in the tenancy example in
the case of a private cloud would be it
will be only a single tenancy since the
private cloud infrastructure is only
dedicated to a single customer or the
single organization whereas in the case
of a hybrid cloud the tenancy is defined
as the data stored in a public cloud is
multi tenant and it is kept securely as
well as private with the help of a
private cloud so we have a public cloud
and we have a hybrid cloud which offers
us the multi-tenancy unlike in the case
of a private cloud but to make it secure
which was not possible in the case of a
public cloud we use the help of a
private cloud to make it more private
and secure in terms
the data now exposure to public how the
public accesses these cloud models so
the public cloud is accessed by everyone
there are very least restrictions or no
restrictions anyone in any from any
place any geography or any device can
access the services whereas the access
of the private cloud can be only done by
the administrators inside the
organization whereas the case of a
hybrid cloud since it's a combination of
a public plus private cloud so it can be
accessed from by the within the
organization if it you are using it and
in the form of a private cloud kind of a
service or if it's in the kind of a
public cloud service it can be accessed
from any location now the data center
locations where exactly the data center
of these cloud models are situated at so
for the public cloud on the internet
with the cloud service providers are
available there itself the data centers
are so the data center locations for the
public cloud are on the same premises
where the cloud provider is located at
so over the public Internet this data
center or the infrastructure can be
accessed the data center location of a
private cloud would be inside the
organization Network only so it will not
be on the public network or the Internet
it would be within the organization and
the hybrid cloud the data center
location inside the organization for
private cloud services and anywhere on
the internet for the public cloud
services so it's up to the organization
so how they have done the deployment if
it's in the form of a public cloud
deployment it can be accessed over the
Internet if it is in the form of a
private cloud deployment done on the
hybrid model it would be access over a
private probably a dedicated network or
over the network which is limited to a
particular organization now the cloud
service providers with respect to the
public cloud and the cloud service
provider manages service whatever the
organization uses them so this is one of
the features of a public cloud service
providers in case of a private cloud
service providers the organization's
need to have their administrators inside
the organization from where the private
cloud is accessed from and in the case
of a hybrid cloud the organization
operates the private cloud whereas the
cloud service provider manages the
public cloud so it can be that the user
can be outside the organization
using the public cloud or the user has
to be inside the organization to access
the private cloud the hardware
components now in the case of a public
cloud the cloud service provider
provides all the hardware's and ensure
it works properly so nothing has to be
implemented or supplied by the
organization or the client to the cloud
service provider everything would be
provided by the cloud service provider
and that's the reason that basically
those people who don't have their
infrastructure or they basically do not
want to procure the infrastructure it's
the best places for a public cloud since
it's available on the Internet it can be
accessed by anyone if the person is not
an organization if it's not the
organization if it's an individual
person also wants to use the public
cloud is the best place in the case of a
private cloud the organization offers
the hardware so organization says that
this is our specification if we just
want that you should put this particular
infrastructure with that specification
into your premises which we can access
it over the netiquette it or the
internal network and that makes it more
expensive now in the case of a hybrid
cloud the organization provides hardware
for the private cloud whereas the cloud
service provider provides you the
infrastructure if in case you are
accessing it in the form of a public
cloud now moving to the expenses let's
see the comparison of the costing
associated with the different cloud
models now coming to the public cloud
model generally what happens in this
case is the public cloud service
provider provides the infrastructure
applications and they host the
applications on their infrastructure at
their premises they give the access off
for those application and the
infrastructure over the network probably
mostly on the internet and hence it
becomes a cheaper option in terms of
accessing the services using a public
cloud now looking to the private cloud
model costing the hardware and network
has to be provided by the organization
that means the company that is
requesting for the infrastructure and
hence it becomes an expensive for the
clients to work on the private cloud
model now looking into the expenses for
the hybrid cloud model it's basically
the costing is intermediate between the
public and the private since the
organization must provide Hardware a
network for the private cloud if they
wanted to access it as a private
loved model then it becomes bit
expensive whereas if they want to access
it like a public cloud model then the
cloud service provider does all the
installation for the cloud so the cost
becomes moderately fair so the top
companies that are using the public
private and the hybrid cloud let's look
into it the public cloud is primarily
used by Amazon Web Services which is one
of the largest cloud service providers
along with that Microsoft Azure and the
Google cloud the IBM earlier it was more
focused on the private cloud now they
are into the public cloud sector as well
the private cloud let's say if the
organization or the clients require that
the set up has to be done on a private
cloud and then they should look for the
private cloud providers like VMware Dell
Oracle or Cisco the hybrid cloud is
being used by amazon HP goggle as well
as the microsoft so these cloud
providers which are using a public cloud
and they also use the hybrid cloud as
well so that's it from us guys and for
more videos just look for our channel
bye for now thank you hi there if you
like this video subscribe to the simple
learn YouTube channel and click here to
watch similar videos to nerd up and get
certified click here